be patient but then when the opportunity
comes D pounds we had a 2-year purchase
on that as well so first come about 2
years ago and then probably 6 months ago
is when we actually got the price agreed
so it took 18 months to agree the price
it happens man it started super high and
it was just the case of our number was
where we thought it was worth we only
ended up 50 Grand above where we started
and they had come down several hundreds
of thousand but it was just them
accepting it so they left it on the
market and no one brought it and in the
end we was the only people left so they
founded us up and said all right you can
have it for this figure that's the thing
about being a patient investor you've
got to be patient I think when it comes
to investing in property